halloween
ends you were set to start filming and
then kovit took over so you haven't done
any of that we have not done any of that
my guess is it will probably happen
early next year
um i think once they figure out a
vaccine and once they figure out the
protocols for work
i think we will go back and finish the
trilogy the last movie has to do with
legacy well jamie's got plenty to keep
her busy right now
she just launched a podcast this week
it's a coming-of-age comedy called
letters from camp good evening acorns
how are we all doing
it's nostalgic it's mysterious and it's
a coming of age of this young 12 year
old girl
and you'll want to listen closely
jamie's godson yes
godson jake gyllenhaal is part of the
weekly scripted comedy
all right all right dudes and dudettes
one two three
eyes on me you just call up you're like
it's your godmother she wants you to
work
that's funny i use that tone all the
time oh you how do you know what i sound
like on the phone
another thing to look out for is jamie's
charity it's called my hand and yours
and it sells works of art to benefit
children's hospital
la it's a way to say in four simple
words
that i'm not with you but i would be
holding your hand right now and i want
you to feel what that would feel like
this is a
little set of hands it's a sculpture of
two hands holding
what does your tattoo say on your finger
fearless
okay that's a word we all need right now
you know what here put that up so
fearless and comfort
we've got this